hey everyone Lars here in the Tesla
engineering crash safety lab and I
wanted to talk a little bit about what
makes our cars so safe passive safety is
what happens after you get in an
accident we think about that from the
beginning of a design and what we're
trying to do is absorb as much energy
from whatever object you hit before it
gets the cabin that's so we always like
to think we have two rules number one
protect the occupant number two protect
the battery see rule number one protect
the occupant the way we do that is in a
progressive nature of Crash structure
this is what it looks a car looks like
underneath the skin you have your bumper
beam your crush can and then you have
what we just debuted in Austin is our
new front underbody casting and what
happens when you get into an accident is
first the bumper being crushes up it
progressively cusses up the crush the
can absorbing the low speed energy under
20 miles per hour and then we get into
our casting the design is such that the
ribs at the beginning of the casting are
thinner than the ones at the back and we
progressively increase them so that we
have controlled crushing of the entire
system as it goes up before it gets to
the cabin here but what else you'll
notice is there's multiple load paths
this is a higher load path for
compatibility with other vehicles on the
road sometimes we need a lower load path
if you hit a different sized object
they're spaced vertically to transfer
the load not only through the crush rail
but also through our subframe which
pulls the Drive Unit down and out of the
way from the cabin behind you and out of
the way of the battery but we don't just
do that in a vertical sense we also do
it laterally your main Crush rail is
great if you hit something up front but
if you hit a pole or a tree just outside
that Crush rail there's nothing there to
absorb an energy in most cars we put our
lower load path just outside that Crush
rail and we actually angle it so that if
you hit something here we start to
absorb the energy and then we push the
car away from whatever object you hit to
make sure that you're not getting
crushed into that object
the backup structure is what protects
the cabin after that and we use both our
door Rings the glass and our battery to
provide structure to hold all of this
energy it's crushing up but one of the
things that's unique about all of
Tesla's is the battery is super low at
lower center of gravity in addition to
our suspension means our vehicles are
less likely to roll over
so let's take a look at what a car looks
like after a crash test and how these
systems all work
so this here is actually a really
special car this is a car that was crash
tested at Nitza for a five-star rating
on model Y and as you can see all that
energy was absorbed up front here
stopping really at the cabin like I was
talking about and we do such a good job
of that
that you can actually open the door and
get out and as you can see aside from a
little bit of white paint and some
airbags blown off the cabin looks like
it was untouched and that means the
occupant inside has all of the room that
they had before the accident to survive
the accident